[Music]  Kris Jenner gets clever when asked about  Kylie's pregnancy never a dull moment  definitely not when trying to keep up  with kardashian-jenner news according to  The Hollywood Reporter during the  Bottega Veneta show on Saturday the 61  year old momager revealed she was  surprised to wake up to reports that her  youngest daughter is pregnant but did  not confirm the news quote it wouldn't  be the family if something didn't happen  every single day this is a milestone  this comes after the news broke on  Friday Kylie is expecting her first  child with rapper Travis Scott though  the 20 year old reality star seemed  unfazed by the media frenzy celebrating  best friend Jordan Woods's birthday with  friends in Malibu for a wine Safari  seemingly hiding her baby bump even  surprising the birthday girl with a  brand new matte black Mercedes talked  about friendship goals  [Music]  you